if you want to start a successful
business you need to run towards
something that you love doing instead of
running away from something that you
hate hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe
that hungry entrepreneurs deserve help
and today maintained a question from one
of my newsletter readers Roshan who
wrote in to say hi Evan I want advice
from you i'm working in the software
company I'm thinking should I leave this
job or should I continue I'm an
accountant in the company I've been here
for one month I'm waiting for your reply
I don't know what to do regards real
shine thank you for the question now
you've only been there for a month so
you got to see if you like it or not but
really if you want to start a business
it has to be around a burning desire to
help people you have a passion for
building something or creating the
service and it helps people that's what
you have to run towards you don't want
to start a business because you hate
your job okay that might be a motivating
factor but if you just start any
business because you're trying to get
out of your job you're not going to be
successful the successful entrepreneurs
are not running away from something that
they hate their running towards building
something that they love and it's a big
difference and it's really important to
understand when you're starting the
business and you might be a great
entrepreneur I don't know I haven't
heard anything in your email that talks
about what type of business you want to
start and it's okay not to know now it's
okay to have this as part of your plan
to research ideas to test things out see
what works see if see if you get excited
by it your passion and your excitement
has to be from starting this new
business because you love it because it
helped people because it fuels you
because you wake up in the morning you
can't wait to start doing this and not
because you hate your job and you don't
know if you should stay there or not for
everybody watching it's the same story
hey who likes her job ninety percent of
America wakes up and they go to work at
some company that I hate doing work
that's beneath them never realizing the
full potential nobody likes her job
almost nobody but that's not enough to
be successful entrepreneur a lot of
entrepreneurs came from the corporate
world they hated their jobs they created
the successful business that's great but
they weren't running away from the
corporate world
running away from a job they were
running towards building an amazing
company around something that they
passionately believed it and so it
encouraged you before you quit your job
find that business idea find what fuels
you find what gets you up in the morning
on the rainy days when you're not making
a lot of money what's going to get you
up in the morning to run a business when
you find that then you're off to the
races then you're ready to get going
good luck for those of you watching you
like the video please give it a thumbs
up below and I'd love to hear what you
have to think please leave a comment
under this video and if you have a
question leave it in comments below I
always read those and makes my morning
when they come in so thank you guys and
I'll see you on the next episode